[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
GARETH MORGAN: Great
to see you all.
Stephen, great to have you here.
First time to Google?
STEPHEN ROCHE: First
time to Google, yeah.
I was going to wear
my pink jersey,
but I watched it too much
and put in the dryer.
GARETH MORGAN: Yours was
much, much, much harder
earned than mine was.
STEPHEN ROCHE: Man, I
put mine in the dryer.
It doesn't fit
anymore, you know?
[LAUGHTER]
GARETH MORGAN: Well, actually,
we'll talk about that.
Because it's 30 years
this month since
you got out on the
start line for the Giro,
for a fantastic season.
Do you remember how you were
feeling when you lined up?
And were you confident
of what was coming?
STEPHEN ROCHE: Well,
in fact, lining up I
was a co-leader with my
teammate Roberto Visentini, who
actually won the Giro in '86.
And I had helped him to win it.
But I had won the Tour of
Romandie going into the Giro.
And I'd won the Tour Valencia,
second at Paris-Nice,
second and whatever.
And I felt that I deserved
at least a level, par kind
of title of leader, co-leader.
And whoever is lucky enough
on the day, he can be leader.
And that's how it was
for the first few days.
Got the team jersey
after day three.
Held the jersey for a week.
And I quickly noticed
that my teammate
was following me, rather
than following the other.
Which was cool to
me, because at least
he was never far away from me.
But at the same time,
if he had been--
I won't say intelligent enough,
but he had been more doing
his own game, he would have been
trying to get away and leave me
behind.
So I should admit, he was
actually never too far from me.
But I was only out
there the first week.
Then we had a big time
trial, and I flopped.
And my biggest
memory of that day
was I had the jersey
for eight days.
I was being claimed as a
hero and everything else.
I quite enjoyed it
and lapped it all up.
And this day, after this time
trial, I came to the finish.
I had lost two
minutes on Visentini.
He got the jersey.
I arrived in, and
nobody gave me a towel.
Nobody said, Stephen,
poor Stephen.
What happened?
Nobody was trying to console me.
And I looked across
to Visentini,
and he was getting
all the adulation.
All the the press and
media were all over him.
And I just heard one remark
when I was going past.
A journalist said to him, well,
Roberto, it's quite clear,
now you've won the time
trial, that you're now
the only sole leader
of the Carrera team.
So Roche now, will ride for you.
But then you can
pay back then, when
you go to the tour in July.
And Roberto politely
turned to the journalist
and said, yeah, it's true.
Stephen will ride for me now.
I'm the sole leader.
I've showed everybody who's
the strongest in the team.
But I'm not going to the tour.
I'm going on holidays.
So I thought well, he's being
honest about it, anyway.
But at the same time, we're
going to ride for the guy.
And he said it quite openly
that there' no pay back.
So it wasn't very fair.
GARETH MORGAN: Now,
he was an Italian
in an Italian team in an Italian
race, obviously, in Italy.
STEPHEN ROCHE:
Previous winner, '86.
GARETH MORGAN: And
a previous winner.
How did the next few
weeks transpire for
you, in terms of winning
over the Italians,
winning over the team,
and winning the race?
STEPHEN ROCHE: Well, actually,
I'm still working on it.
Because you can imagine, as you
said, taking the pink leader
jersey off an Italian,
riding for an Italian team,
previous Giro winner, a
great Italian hopeful,
it was quite
devastating for him.
And the public made
me feel that they
were devastated for him also.
But the very next day,
after the time trial,
had to have a talk with myself.
Had to kind of Google help, and
what can I do next, you know?
And we decided that myself and
my teammate, Eddie Schepers--
my teammate and roommate--
the only guy that
was really with me,
said, well, what do we do?
He's annihilated
everybody today.
So he's obviously going very
deep, going into the pain zone.
And normally He would have had
to recover for the next day.
So if he'd had to
recover the next day,
well, the following day
was a mountain stage.
So we won't be able to
catch him out at all.
So the next day was a
kind of transition stage,
a bit of a Mickey Mouse stage.
So we thought, well, if
something stupid could happen,
has to happen today.
So we set out with
no real ambition
to upset the applecart.
But if it's an
opportunity, why not?
So a break, we got away.
We had no Carrera
teammates in there.
So I thought, well,
it's not my place
to be there, because I
was kind of a co-leader.
But at the same time,
if I got into the break,
it would save my team from
chasing the breakaway down.
But then there's nobody
dangerous in the group.
So I have no real reason
to be there either.
[SIGHS]
So I was fighting with myself.
So I decided, OK, well,
I can't attack, because I
would seen to be attacking.
So what if I just go
over the top of the hill
and just don't look behind
me, and see what happens
at the bottom of the hill?
So I went down the
hill quite fast,
and got to the
bottom of the hill.
I had nearly a minute and a
half up on the main group.
And I caught the front group.
So I didn't attack though.
I went down the hill
faster than him.
[LAUGHTER]
People keep saying, even 30
years on, ah, Stephen, oh, you
shouldn't have
attacked your teammate.
But I just want
to make it clear.
I didn't attack.
I went faster than
him on the downhill.
It's clear, yeah?
Mhm?
[LAUGHTER]
Then, all of a
sudden, the team car
came along and said,
Stefano, what are you doing?
I said, well, I went
down the hill quite fast.
Very surprised
nobody followed me.
Now I'm in the break.
At least my team
now are at ease.
They can sit behind and wait for
the Bianchis and the Panasonics
to arrive.
And the guy says, Stefano,
you don't understand.
There's mayhem behind you.
They're on the ground.
They're hanging out in threes.
They're everywhere,
ones and twos.
You went down that hill so
fast, they're everywhere.
It's totally
disorganized behind you.
You're going to get away.
Well, that's what it's
all about, isn't it?
No, Stefano, you
don't understand.
Roberto's riding behind you.
I said, oh.
That's not very
good of a teammate.
Tell Roberto to
stop and I'll stop.
No, no, no, Stefano.
You don't understand.
Roberto wants you to stop.
But I said no.
Tell him, he stops, I stop.
He rides, I ride harder.
And that was kind
of war was declared.
And I told him, just tell
Roberto not to give it at all.
Because when he catches
me, I'm going again.
So that's what
actually happened.
And he caught me
on the final climb.
And I struggled like
terrible in the final climb,
Because I'd done like,
45K riding in the front.
And my teammate, Eddy
Schepers was right beside me.
And he came up
beside me, Stephen,
this is the day
you win the Giro.
You've got to catch
that breakaway now
because there's a group of
four or five guys ahead, Tony
Rominger, Steve Bauer.
You got to catch that guy.
This is the day
you win the Giro.
And I buried myself
over the top.
And I finished like, four or
five seconds behind the group
on the finish line.
But just one second
ahead of Tony Rominger
to put on the pink jersey.
Which doesn't sound a lot.
But I could've imagined
another scenario.
After everything
that had happened,
taking the jersey off an Italian
rider, in an Italian race,
in an Italian team.
They wouldn't have been
very sympathetic with me
at the finish.
My boss had come along
to sign me a new contract
for the following year.
So all of a sudden, the
boss got his helicopter,
went home, and left me to deal
with a very annoyed public.
And he couldn't send me
home because I had a jersey.
And Roberto lost
four or five minutes.
So the scenario there
was for one second,
the whole history
could've been changed.
And of course, we had no
earplugs those days either.
So we didn't know
what was happening.
So then after that, things
got quite complicated.
GARETH MORGAN: And was
that the day you knew
you were going to win the Giro?
STEPHEN ROCHE: That was the
day I realized how hostile
the Italian public can be.
[LAUGHTER]
Because even today, for
example, even though we all
feel cocky and everything else,
somebody would say to you,
Stephen, here's a scenario.
What would you do
in this scenario?
And if someone was to
describe that scenario to me
today, after not living
that scenario, I said,
there's no way I'd
have stayed there.
I'd have gone home.
And the first plane
home, I'd have been home.
Because it was an
incredible scenario.
And the very next day, the
people were spitting at me,
shouting all kinds
of abuse at me,
spitting rice mixed
with wine at me.
All kinds of slogans
which I can't mention here
because there's too
many young people here.
It's absolutely amazing.
And for the first day, I wasn't
allowed to talk to the press.
So I couldn't get my
side of the story across.
But the next morning, I
spoke to a journalist.
I told him to be
my spokesperson.
And he took my story
and very politely said
to me, once it was all finished,
Stephen, story's great,
you know?
The only thing is, all the
articles are done for tomorrow.
So I have tomorrow.
I can promise you, your
article will be in the paper
the following day.
I'll tell your side.
So it made things very,
very complicated for me.
And very next day, then I'm on
the podium, getting my flowers.
And it wasn't as
luxurious as it is today.
It was like a back
of a big truck.
There was the podium.
There was a plastic,
plexi kind of curtain.
Behind that curtain, that
was the live television.
So I was saying to myself,
like I can't leave this camera.
I'm going to get killed here.
Someone's going to kill me.
It was really, really hostile.
Had to tell my
side of the story.
So I took my flowers
around the bit.
And I walked over gently
towards the two guys
on the front door of
these plastic doors
for the live television.
Threw my flowers
out to the public.
And the same time, barged in
between these two big guys
that were standing there
to protect the live set.
And I burst into live set.
The journalist says
bah-- uh-- eh-- uh--
we-- uh-- uh-- we
have a surprise guest.
Stephen, I suppose you've
come in to surprise us.
I'm sure you've come in to
tell your side of the story.
The story of Sappada,
they call it.
So I said yes.
So at that particular day, I
realized for the first time
I could actually speak Italian.
And I put a few words
together to explain
my side of the story.
It helped a little bit.
But you can imagine,
in Italy, they
didn't want to hear about it.
GARETH MORGAN: Yeah.
STEPHEN ROCHE: So things were
extremely difficult and hostile
for the next 10 days.
GARETH MORGAN: Is there
any Italians in the room?
Oh, they're all
watching live TV.
Well, it all worked
out very well.
You ended up being the first
Irish person to win the Giro.
And we'll talk about the rest
of the season later on as well.
But I wanted to go back
to the very beginning.
Because you're a local
boy, born and bred
out the road, in Dundrum.
What got you interested in
cycling in the first place?
STEPHEN ROCHE: It was
quite by accident, really.
I played football with my
local lads after school.
I thought it was good.
But I always watched them
playing on the Sunday,
even though I trained
with them all week.
Which wasn't very
nice, you know?
And I swam fairly strong,
but I wasn't really
a straight swimmer.
I swam off to the side, which
is very embarrassing when
you're in the pool.
And one day I was
playing football
in the middle of
our housing estate.
And maybe not so much
these days, but in those
days there was always
one person, at least,
in a housing estate that
knew everybody's business.
And this particular person,
her husband actually cycled.
So she knew I used to ride on
my bike, had a paper round.
I used to deliver the
papers on my bike.
And I'd go up to
Glencree on a Sunday
where they had a little
[INAUDIBLE] store where they'd
make my bangers and my sausages
and think it was great,
you know?
Think I'd gone to
the end of the world.
And I'm back.
But this woman knew that I had
a little interest in cycling.
And she was coming down
from the shops one day.
And she crossed by the green
where we played football.
And she says, Stephen, you
like riding a bike, don't you?
I didn't ask her.
I was too polite to
ask her how she knew.
But looking back
it, now we know why.
But anyway, she said, there's
a new Cycling Club starting up
at H. Williams at
7:30, next Wednesday.
If you want to go
along, go along.
So I went along.
And I was told I had
to be 13 to join.
I was only 12 and 1/2.
So I told them I was 13.
And I joined the club.
And went on from there.
But I didn't actually
jump at it straight away.
I enjoyed it because I
was training with my mates
all week, or
whenever I had time.
And on the weekend I went out
and rode a race with my mates.
And the first race we
rode was in Skerries.
And after a couple
of laps, I stopped.
I was riding my friend's
bike, because my bike wasn't
good enough.
I was wearing jeans
and a pair of shoes.
And the jeans were rolled up.
And it was on a small closed
circle in the Skerries.
About two laps to go, I
pulled on the side of the road
and the coach came
running after me.
Stephen, Stephen, what's wrong?
What's wrong?
Nothing.
Why'd you stop?
I was tired.
So I stopped.
But the beauty of it
was, I was cycling
and competing with
the mates that I
was training with all week.
And then we raced
every other week.
And we got on better and better,
from strength to strength.
But I never really
a super rider.
But I enjoyed what I was doing.
And that's probably what
made me stick in it.
GARETH MORGAN: Mhm.
So clearly you've learned a
lot about cycling and training
for cycling over the years.
Here's a question for you.
Because there's lots
of avid cyclers here.
Let's say you pick somebody
from the audience here,
and you've got eight weeks to
get them ready for the Tour de
France.
[LAUGHTER]
What are you going to focus on?
[SIGHS]
[LAUGHTER]
STEPHEN ROCHE: That's
a very, very big task.
I'd focus on well,
maybe, getting time
off work, first of all.
And trying to find a
good training program.
But no, I'm training myself at
the moment, for our own event
we're doing.
And we're having kind
of a tour back to '87.
We're going to do
the '87 21st stage
of the tour over three days.
And I'm starting to
train for it now myself.
But it's a big task
for me, because I
haven't been training a lot.
But looking at the
people here today,
I don't see much talent
here for cycling.
GARETH MORGAN: All the
Italians are missing.
That's why.
STEPHEN ROCHE: I could be making
a mistake maybe, you know?
But at least, watch the
Giro, next few weeks.
You might get a few tips.
GARETH MORGAN: Uh-huh.
Well, I mean, training has
changed a lot since 1987
to today.
And obviously you're
a keen observer
of how the cyclists
prepare themselves today.
In fact, I hear you're
commentating on the Giro
starting tomorrow,
for French TV.
What's your observations
on how training has
changed over the last 30 years?
And particularly,
what things would
you do differently,
based on what
you know now, if you were
going back to do 1987 again?
STEPHEN ROCHE:
I'll ask my parents
to be born 10 years later.
Because when they see the
money that's going around now,
they say well, you
know, I wonder,
have you got a case there?
A legal case, you know?
[LAUGHS]
But no, everything has
changed, totally changed.
And it's difficult.
We never look at it
and say, our time was better
than today or today is not
as good as yesterday.
We all deal with it
at our own times.
And we look at the
Nicolas, for example,
today, who is racing with BMC.
And you see his lifestyle,
you look at his bank account
and you say, yeah,
it's brilliant.
But at the same time,
look at the lifestyle.
You say, well, it's
not money for nothing.
You know?
GARETH MORGAN: How is
the lifestyle different?
STEPHEN ROCHE: Well--
GARETH MORGAN: So
Nicolas is your son?
STEPHEN ROCHE:
He's my son, yeah.
Well, for example, I
had ridden say, 37,000,
38,000 kilometers a year.
I'd have been racing
120 days of the year.
Again today, 65
days a year, maybe.
Christopher might
do 50 days a year.
So it's a lot less competition.
And that's why maybe today some
of the riders go till 38, 40.
Whereas in our day it was
31, 32, 33, because we
were riding twice as much.
But we started
racing in February,
and finished off in October.
And we're hitting peaks like
in March, for Paris-Nice,
in May for the Romandie or
Giro, for July, for the Tour.
In August, for the end-of-season
Classics, in September,
for the World Championships, and
then for Lombardy in October.
They we'd have a break.
I used to always
say, being stubborn,
you don't get paid
for staying at home.
So you got to race.
You don't get paid for training.
You got to race.
Win a race, you get paid.
Training, there's no money.
Got to train, then race.
Whereas today it's,
I focus on the race.
I train for that race.
And I try and win that race.
And it might mean
taking five weeks out
in the middle of the season.
Whereas for us, that
was totally unheard of.
We'd do a three-week
training block in February.
And that was it for the year.
And we were afraid
of taking time out.
Because you're afraid
of losing the condition.
Because you, all the time,
ask yourself the question,
will it come back?
I left off at here.
When I get back on,
will it be the same?
You're always worried about it.
Whereas today, with all the
data available to the guys,
the power meters, the watt
meters, the heart monitors,
and all the science
there is behind it,
they can tell you
exactly where they are.
They haven't got to go
out on the bike and say,
I'm going to go well today.
They know, merely from
the numbers, how they are
and where they are.
It's all gone so scientific.
But at the same
time, the downside
is I'm asking myself well,
do they enjoy it as much?
Because we really enjoyed it.
Whereas when you're
riding a bike today,
you're looking at the watts.
And you're wondering why
they aren't going up.
Or you're getting
up in the morning
and say they're going to do six
hours, that's 3,000 calories.
Well, I've only eaten 1,500.
So I'm going to
lose so many grams.
It's all full-time, 24/7,
all the time, on the ball.
Whereas we would get
up in the morning,
7:00, 7:30, have
a good breakfast,
go off and ride the bike.
Didn't really matter what
we had in our pockets.
We'd ride a bike.
Hail, rain, or snow,
we'd ride a bike.
Today the guys are getting up.
They're nearly
weighing their food,
what the protein is,
the calories, and this,
and the carbs.
Everything is all monitored.
They function to what
train they're doing.
Where we trained in groups, now
they all train as individuals.
Because they all have a
different training program.
And everyone's are
all so different.
So it's become
unsociable as well.
Definitely, if I was thrown
into this peloton today,
I wouldn't cope.
But the guys today have grown
up with this, and the numbers.
And it's all about numbers.
And which is, I think for the
kids, has been unfortunate.
Because they don't know
how to enjoy the bike.
For example, I have another
son, Alexis, he was 18.
And he went for a trial for
the 82R Cycling Club there,
about a few weeks ago.
And 19 or 20 guys went
for the same interview.
And I spoke to the
coach afterwards.
And the coach said,
Stephen, there
were 2 guys of 20
that appealed to me.
One was your son.
I said, why?
Because he spoke to me about
himself, what he was doing,
his plans, what he
was doing in school,
what job he was looking for.
Whereas the other
guys were talking
about how many
watts they're doing,
what their recovery rate,
how many heartbeats they have
and everything
else, what they've
done in the O2 max test
and everything else,
whereas Alexis has
never done one.
Because I always said, Alexis,
there's time for that later on.
Learn the feeling of your legs.
Learn the feeling of your body
when you're under pressure.
And then start
working on the watts.
But working on the
watts when you're young?
16, 17, 18 years of age?
That's when you learn
to enjoy the bike.
Which means when
you're 21, 22, 23,
and you start needing
to get into the watts,
the nitty-grittys of the
real scientific training,
he'd have been doing
it all at a young age
and have never enjoyed that.
When the times
get tough, I think
that's where it all comes out.
You go to playing
football or playing
golf or marbles or something.
But it's difficult to stay
in cycling when you have
to do it for a full lifetime.
That's why I think
the riders today,
the lifestyle is very hard.
Because it's full on.
It's 24/7.
And it's a very difficult
lifestyle they have.
GARETH MORGAN: Now,
Stephen, you mentioned
reaching a number of peaks in
the season when you were back
in '87.
Obviously winning
the Giro was a peak.
And then a couple
of weeks later,
I think three weeks
later, you were
lining up for the Tour de
France and feeling confident
going into that race.
STEPHEN ROCHE: Well,
I just won the Giro,
and under very
difficult circumstances.
So of course, I was worried
about my general condition.
But I decided that between
the Giro and the Tour,
there was only like, 18
days, I think it was.
And I suffered an awful
lot morally and physically.
But not very, very
severely morally.
So I thought well, that
Giro tour was 26 days.
It's the longest
one since the war,
and the most mountainous
since the war.
So I wasn't a great climber.
I was a good climber.
So going into a tour
which was very mountainous
was going to be
difficult for me.
So I decided OK, well, I'll
hide for the three weeks
between the Giro and Tour.
Because going to
races, everybody's
going to be talking about
Visentini, how I got it,
how I didn't get it, how I
lost it, why did I attack him
and why didn't I attack him?
So I don't answer that again.
So let's just get on with
it and prepare for the tour.
So the first week I
just rode the bike.
Just promenading and
just riding the bike
whenever I felt like it.
And the second week, start
building up the distance.
And the third week,
I started training
on the motorbike doing
like, once in the morning,
once in the evening
time, doing short spins.
But not too tiring,
but fast spins.
Because my idea was that
after winning the Giro,
going to the Tour, If you
don't show the first day,
people say well, it was a
fluke or it doesn't matter.
Whereas, I wanted
to show everybody
that the Giro wasn't a fluke.
And the Tour, I always have it
marked as one of my priorities.
So I finished third in the
Prologue, which is good for me.
Because I was showing everybody
that I was still in form.
And that particular
tour, I broke it up
into seven or eight days.
Because you cannot be
on form for 26 days.
So you pick out the
days that suit you,
which is the Prologue.
Show everybody you're here.
Stay safe for the
first time trial.
Do your best in the
next time trial.
And I won that.
Then you go on into the
first mountain stage,
and you try and perform on it.
So that was my strategy.
Up to the Alps.
And then the Alps, I say,
OK, I can identify now
who my rivals are and
how can I beat them?
It a lot of that was strategy.
Which a lot of it today
is not as strategic.
It's more scientific.
But in our day there
was a lot of strategy
and you always had to
work on the other guy
and know his strong
points, his weak points,
and try and work on them.
GARETH MORGAN: And your
favorite moment from that Tour?
STEPHEN ROCHE: The
favorite moment of the Tour
was probably a dramatic moment
for everybody, especially
my family.
Because when I collapsed at
the finish line on La Plagne,
it's an event that everybody
talks about today still.
Because it was moving at
20 down with 5K to go.
And I pulled out all the
stops and brought it back down
to four seconds on
the finish line.
But I had brought back the
gap down in a short period.
It was purposely done,
everything I had.
Because I knew that if I
had wrecked it earlier,
Delgado might accelerate.
Whereas by him having 120 up
but 5K to go, he's going to say,
OK, I'm happy now.
I've got Roche now.
I'm OK in the lead.
I have 120 ahead,
so I won the tour.
And I was thinking, well,
I'll let him think that.
And then with 4K to go, 5K to
go, give it everything I have.
And then and I'll
try and get back
to behind 30 seconds of
him And then surprise them.
So that that's why I did.
But I came right
back to four seconds.
So the problem was that
the journalists were all
saying, well, Laurent
Fignon won the stage.
So they're all over
Laurent Fignon.
They were on Delgado
winning the Tour.
And they were on peloton.
But Roche is in
the middle where he
lost the Tour and no sympathy.
So when Roche came out of
nowhere, all of a sudden,
the journalists
had their articles
already pre-written as
to Delgado won the tour.
And Roche went into anonymous.
And then Roche comes
round the corner.
So the journalists were
running towards Delgado.
And all of a sudden,
they come over to me.
So nobody wanted to
help me off my bike
because they were all
looking for the first word.
But I couldn't talk.
So I collapsed on
the finish line.
And the one thing
I remember most,
the most frightening thing was
that I'm lying on the ground.
And I can't move
my arms, my legs.
Can't move them.
And the guys are saying,
Stephen, move your legs in.
The ambulance, the car
is getting close to you.
And I couldn't move my legs.
And the doctor's
saying, Stephen,
blink your eyes if
you can hear me.
So I communicated with the
Doctor for five minutes
with my eyes, just
yes, no, yes, no,
until I started coming around.
Then they put me in the
back of the ambulance.
And then things
got a bit better.
But it was a frightening moment.
But for me, it was a moment--
well, historic moment really.
Because that's the day I
could've lost the Tour.
And it was an epic day.
I had attacked over the
[INAUDIBLE],, like, 100K to go.
It was suicidal, but I did it.
And I was caught.
My plan backfired.
But I still came back to save
the day on that tiny stage.
So for me, that's probably the
most memorable day of the Tour.
Maybe because everyone
talks about it, even today.
And it's still so
fresh in my mind.
But it is a famous
day in cycling,
and a famous commentary
from Phil Liggett,
because Phil Liggett was
the only one really watching
the monitor that day.
And when he saw
me coming he said,
that looks like
Roche. that is Roche.
And his words are very
famous, even to this day,
for the live commentary.
GARETH MORGAN: Yeah.
I remember that Tour very well.
I was there on the
Champs-Elysees that day.
I was very young.
STEPHEN ROCHE: You weren't
wearing glasses then, were you?
[LAUGHTER]
GARETH MORGAN: And
it was at a time
when we didn't have very
many Irish sporting heroes.
In fact, I think of you
as a pioneer in that.
It wasn't until 1988 that the
Irish football team qualified
for their first big event.
Since since then
we've been spoiled.
But you were a real pioneer.
Was there a moment after
that where you went, wow,
I really made the big time?
STEPHEN ROCHE: Big time, no.
But I didn't really
realize the impact
it was having back
here in the country.
Because the late Charles
Haughey, [INAUDIBLE]
met me on the podium in Paris.
GARETH MORGAN: Never
missed a photo op.
STEPHEN ROCHE: Never
missed a photo opportunity.
And I didn't really
know-- well, I
knew who he was, OK, but I
wasn't intimate with him.
I would kind of say well,
what's he doing here?
Should I say hello to him?
Should I ask him
to go for a pint?
Or what do I say to him?
Anyway, he'd already
had a few pints.
But when he was finished with
the protocol and everything
else, he leaned on my
shoulder and said well,
every day [INAUDIBLE],,
cup of coffee.
And he was totally stoned.
But I took him to his word.
And before I go into that one,
I came home the following day
into Dublin.
And of course, Charles Haughey
was waiting for me there,
for the plane, with
a fabulous welcoming.
And I'm coming home
saying, on the plane, well,
I'm going to look
like I need you here.
Back in Dublin, getting
off a plane and nobody
in the airport.
Because the 525 cycling
fans are all in Paris.
They can't get home to meet me.
So I'm going to look
bloody stupid, getting off
a plane for a reception
and have nobody there.
So anyway, to my surprise,
I got off the plane,
and there was thousands of
people all over the tarmac.
They had banners up
all over the airport.
And when I got off
the plane, then
the crowds jumped the barriers,
went out to the tarmac.
And the police had to
make a human [INAUDIBLE]
so I could walk through.
Like really, Elvis
Presley, Beatles stuff.
It was amazing.
People were pulling at me,
and absolutely amazing.
Absolutely amazing.
And they had a civic reception.
The bus ride then,
from the airport
to Dublin, civic reception
in a mansion house.
From there out to my house.
So that was an
amazing day for me.
Because there was so many
people that day in Dublin,
and had come to greet
me at my homecoming.
And I realized then the
impact, that they were
watching television at home.
They were watching the papers.
They were not so
much on social media,
because there wasn't
so much at the time.
But they were following what was
going on and really appreciated
what I did.
But getting back to the
Charles Haughey thing.
People say he stole the show.
But in all fairness, I had
a little story to tell.
They actually went down to his
house a couple of months later.
Because we'd had an
event in Malahide.
And I called in.
And they stopped me at the box.
Then I introduced myself.
They told me to
go up to the door.
And the door was open.
And the late Charles
Haughey came out
of a meeting with
his Aran sweater
on him, a pair of Aran slippers.
Hey, Stephen, I'm
in a meeting here.
Go to the bar at
the bar at the back
and I'll meet you
in five minutes.
So he came in the
back room anyway.
And there was no journalist,
nobody around, just himself,
myself.
And we left the
world and everything
else for about two hours.
At the end of it all,
he went into a back room
with a velvet curtain.
And he came back out
with a box of chocolates
and brushed the dust off and
says, give it to the wife.
I held him to his word.
Gave the chocolates to
the wife, of course.
But I mean, on the podium in
Paris, he got a lot of stick
for coming over and greeting me.
But he said to me,
Stephen, (SLURRED)
everyone's turning around.
He was a bit-- so I call in.
And he welcomes me.
And we saw each other, spoke
about everything and anything
for two hours with no
journalists and nobody else
around.
For me, it was a great,
great moment for me,
to be sitting with
a person like that,
and to be just talking
to a normal person.
GARETH MORGAN: So the first
Irish winner of the Tour de
France, the only Irish winner
of the Tour de France so far.
Who's your bet for the next
Irish winner of the Tour de
France?
STEPHEN ROCHE: I wouldn't
mind keeping it in the family.
GARETH MORGAN: Uh-huh.
Well, you've plenty of options.
STEPHEN ROCHE: Well, Nicolas
now is getting a bit long
in the tooth.
But Alexis, he's coming up.
He's very, very good.
Well, he's got
incredible potential.
I don't want to put any
pressure on the kid now,
but he's got great potential.
But his passion is IT.
He's doing very well at it.
So he has an option.
But he loves the cycling as
well and he's got great talent.
So we'll see where it goes.
But I don't know who the
next Irish person will be
or if he's even born yet.
But I did a charity event down
the Leinster Loop, down in down
in Athy, down in
Kildare last year.
We have a family
ride on the Saturday.
And I was riding along
with a young kid, about 11,
12 years of age.
And he was riding with
all this cycling gear.
I said to him, what do you
want to be when you grow up?
He says, I want to be the next
Irish winner of The Tour de
France.
So maybe it was him.
GARETH MORGAN: Good.
STEPHEN ROCHE: Maybe it was him.
GARETH MORGAN: Good OK.
Let's go into the darker
side of the sport.
Because obviously there's
been a lot of talk
over the last while
about drugs in sport,
and particularly in cycling.
And in fact, actually, I
looked that the last Tour de
France that you rode
in, you were riding
with a certain Texan who
was doing his first Tour de
France, and very infamously
ran into lots of trouble
after that.
What's your thoughts
on drugs in this sport?
STEPHEN ROCHE: Well,
the drugs, I always
ask the people, where does
cheating begin and end?
They have this thing now,
they call it a sticky bottle.
Where any of you
involved in cycling
know what a sticky
bottle is, it's
actually when you see
the rider wants a bottle.
So he put his hand out.
The car comes up.
And all of a sudden, the
rider goes fast forward.
And he's pushing
himself off the car.
I say, for example, that's where
cheating begins also, there.
Without getting into
the doping side of it.
Cheating starts there.
And getting back onto
a group after having
a wee or a puncture, being
stuck back in by the car,
right up to the back
of the bunch, I say
don't wait till somebody gets
in the car, gets back up,
gets out of the car before
doing something about it.
But unfortunately, the UCI
don't listen to me anymore.
And last year we saw Nibali
doing this similar thing.
he got dropped.
He had a problem.
And the first group was
going away from him.
And he got a sticky bottle.
And we saw, from the helicopter,
his speed went from 40 to 70k
an hour.
And about a kilometer or so
he caught the group in front.
And at the end, he even tried
defending himself as to why?
Why is everybody
getting onto me?
You know, why?
They didn't have an
accident or an incident.
Whereas for me, all those things
are all incidents of the race.
That's what makes it the race.
You can't be doing it.
But on the darker side of
it, on the drug side of it,
I was always against it.
And I must say that the last
two generations have had it
very hard.
Because we've been telling
all the kids to stay clean
and don't cheat.
But they've been riding
against riders who they know
are more than likely cheating.
And I used to say
back in the '80s
that you could say 10% of the
peloton might be cheating.
And the others are
suspected of cheating.
Whereas in the '90s and
2000s, we were saying well,
90% of them are cheating and
then 10% might be cheating.
And that all came out in
all the different books that
were written over the
last couple of years
that it was true.
d
GARETH MORGAN: Where
do you think it is now?
STEPHEN ROCHE: I reckon it's
gone back to where it was.
I really hope that there'll
be even less than 10%
still doing it.
It can never be proven.
But with the biological passport
now and the whereabouts system,
it's getting more
and more complicated
for guys to cheat
without being caught.
But as you know, there's always
something new on the market
that we don't know about.
And we always feel that there's
always somebody a little bit
further ahead.
But I'm confident
that the UCI are doing
the utmost to make it clean.
But it's all about education.
Like, why did it get so bad?
It got so bad because
the young kids
were going out with the
[INAUDIBLE] on the weekends
and riding the race.
They were coming in
crying because they've
got sore legs, which is normal.
And then you go to the local
GP and say, listen, [INAUDIBLE]
has sore legs and [INAUDIBLE]
still in the race.
Can you give me something?
And he's giving him whatever, an
aspirin or whatever, a vitamin
C. And then the following
it's something else.
Then it's something else.
Then it gets into
the high-end drugs.
That the young kid
gets a pro contract.
He knows all his life
he's been using whatever.
So he has to use it to perform.
So he continues on with it.
And that's where the cycling
got to over the years.
Because the kids
were starting off
young because there
was no control in it.
And the GPs were giving out
anything and everything.
It took like, two generations
to pull it back a bit.
And of course, all
the different books
that were written about it
highlighted all the problems
and made everyone aware of
what is and what was going on.
And then, of course,
all the controls
that were being put in
place, the Whereabout
system, the biological
passport, which is amazing.
Normal cyclists now
will do a minimum 14
controls in the year, without
even being randomly tested.
He has to also tell everybody.
They have an app where they
have to put in their program.
They call it the
Whereabouts Program.
So if, for example, Nicolas
coming to me on a Saturday,
he has a phone and this
app, and going to my dad
and [INAUDIBLE] and Antibes.
If the last minute
he changes his mind,
go to his grandmother
or whatever,
he has to put it in there.
Because this base
serves for the Olympic
Council, the National
Federations, the UCI.
They can look at this
and say, OK this guy,
we're going to want to test him.
Where is he?
Ah, we're going to test him.
And the rider has to be
within two hours of where
he said he would be.
If he's not, he gets
a first warning.
Then they get a second warning.
And a third warning,
he's positive.
Declared positive and suspended.
So nobody wants to have
that on their record.
So it is getting very, very
hard for riders or athletes that
are trying to cheat to cheat.
But unfortunately,
there's always
somebody ahead of the posse.
But you know, I see in the
racing today, young riders that
are new to the sport, have
understood that you're not
going to win by cheating.
It's about hard work,
dedication, and training.
GARETH MORGAN: And talking
about today and hard work
and dedication and training,
the leading favorite
going into the Tour de France
this year is Chris Froome.
How would you have
fared against him?
STEPHEN ROCHE: What a question.
[LAUGHS]
GARETH MORGAN: How would
you have beaten him?
Or would you have
written for Team Sky?
STEPHEN ROCHE: Yeah, I think
that my Carrera team back
in the '80s was the equivalent
or similar to the Team Sky,
except we were more tactically--
I'd say we could do
really, our own tactics.
We spoke about tactics together.
And we employed what
we felt was necessary.
Whereas the Sky team
are told what to do.
And sometimes you can call
the guys like, brain dead.
An example like, not
insulting the guys,
but like two years ago in
Italy, with Sky, he at one
stage they told Nicolas,
you're now on the front
now from 80 to 120K.
Which means that whatever
happens between those two
limits, he has to make sure
nothing goes without him.
That particular day,
the Movie Star team
were riding for some
reason or whatever.
And Nicolas felt, it's great.
I can have a handy ride.
So after 120K,
Nicolas, how are you?
Great.
OK, see you tomorrow.
He said, I feel good.
No, no, no, tomorrow.
Whereas Nicolas felt really,
really bad about that.
And I can understand that.
But then the very next day,
the team had a bad day.
And Froome was challenged
on Alpe d'Huez.
And Nicolas was the only
one to basically help him.
So you can understand
the strategy there,
that if Nicolas buried
himself yesterday for nothing,
he wouldn't have had the
energy to be the front.
So it's become so scientific
now, that's where it's gone to.
You ride there and
there and there.
And you save the energy
for when we really need it.
You got a job to do.
But Sky has gone a little
bit overboard on it.
But they're going very tactical
and very scientific on us.
And it is killing a bit of
the suspense in the races.
But the answer to
your question, I
think I would have had a
good go at Froome, yeah.
And although I could never
have been as light as him.
But nevertheless,
Froome was a great guy
and a great ambassador
for cycling.
Because he has had
a lot of shit thrown
at him over the last couple
of years because of what's
been going on in cycling in
general, but not himself.
And he has stood up
to it very, very well.
He's answered politely and
correctly to the journalists,
rather than breaking their nose.
Which other riders would have
broken the journalist's noses.
You know?
So he has been a great
ambassador for cycling.
And I think that this year he
strives on people knocking him.
People say, well, Quintana
will win the Tour this year
because Froome isn't going well.
That's fueling his
energy, fueling his motor.
And boy, he'll be hard
to beat this year again.
But I think that if we
can take some conclusions
from last year's tour, we saw a
batch of young guys coming up,
Pinot, Bardet, Barguil,
Dumoulin, Yates.
Load of young guys coming
up, 24, 25 years of age,
who are not worried
about being second.
They want to win.
Whereas for years,
riders were riding
to be second on the
podium behind Froome
or behind Indurain,
or behind whatever.
All of a sudden, they
have the ambition to win.
And they believe they can win.
And for that reason, I think,
for the next 5, 10 years,
we're going to live some
really, really good tours.
GARETH MORGAN: Good.
That's good to hear.
I think we're going to have
time for one or two questions.
Here's the first one.
AUDIENCE: Hey,
how are you doing?
Later that year,
in '87, when you
were in the final kilometer
of the World Championship
race, myself and all
my friends thought
that you were going to lead
Kelly for a sprint finish.
And I think a lot of the riders
in the Bush thought that too.
And when you broke and
nobody followed you,
I'd like to know, what was the
plan between yourself and Kelly
before the race?
And how did all that change?
Or what happened?
What was going through your
head when you went and nobody
followed you?
STEPHEN ROCHE: Well, the deal
was that I'd won the Giro,
I'd won the tour.
And Sean, unfortunately,
he crashed out of the tour.
Hadn't had a great season.
So the World that
year was supposed
to be designed, more or less,
for a rider like Sean, that
wasn't all-arounder,
but a good sprinter.
So that was Sean's year
to be World Champion.
That year or the following
year, but that year
was definitely the year
that was suited for him.
And I basically went down.
And I was very tired
after winning my double.
And I had no real
ambition going down there,
other than to help Sean.
Because everybody had said,
oh, it's a dead, flat circuit.
Wait and see, the
sprinter's race.
I'm only going to up the
numbers and to help Sean.
And it was only after arriving
down like, two days, three days
before, we went
around the circuit.
And I realized well,
gee, this is OK.
A sprinter, it goes around once.
But we're going around 22
times, with 2 climbs every lap.
And I was saying that
most of these sprinters
are going to be tired
at the end of the road.
So I could have a chance.
Which, in a way,
was good for me.
Because I spent
the last few months
just thinking about
helping Sean, and getting
to the end of my season.
I wasn't even
thinking one second
that I did which I was just and
nobody was kind of targeting me
as a favorite either
because they recognized that
I'd done too much in the Giro
in the tour, that I'd be
wasted for the Worlds.
And another aspect that
helped me very much also
was the fact that it had been
35 degrees the day before.
I was totally wasted
because of the fatigue
of the Giro and the Tour.
But the morning of the
race, we opened the curtains
and it's eight degrees
and lashing rain.
It wasn't Malahide or
Swords, or Dundrum,
but we like lashings
of rain in September.
It was amazing, amazingly cold.
And straight away, something
clicks and you say,
well, hmm, somebody's
telling me something here.
And you see things as well.
Like everyone opens the
curtains up the same way.
And someone will say
well, shit, it's raining.
all of a sudden, they're beaten.
Some don't like the rain.
Some will fall off.
Some won't be on form.
Some won't-- you know, we all
have our problems in the rain
and the sun.
Your 200 opponents, all of
a sudden it comes down say,
50 and 20 direct
rivals, you know?
So I thought, OK, well,
the best thing to do
is keep dry for the first part
of the race as much as I can,
hide.
And then the second
part of the race
just try and be available to
help Sean and wait and see.
So with two laps to go, then
Sean had missed a break.
And I had done a lot
of work before then.
So I was a bit
starting to feel it.
It was 272 kilometers.
So I was starting to feel
a bit under the weather
while it was raining.
And I accelerated a little
bit, brought Sean out to front.
We cut the group in front.
And I went straight
to the front to make
sure the break got away.
So once the break
was established,
then I came back to the back.
Thinking, OK, well, I
better just take a rest.
Because if I'm going to lead
Sean out for the sprint,
I can't just lead out for 10K.
I got to lead out
the final 4 or 5.
So as I got to the back then,
two or three guys attacked.
Nobody chased.
So I thought gee, I've been
working all day for Sean.
Here these guys are,
riding away from us.
So I jumped across it.
I'm thinking that the break,
the group would come after me.
But they didn't
react straightaway.
So I found myself in
this four-man break.
And out of the four men-- there
was five of us with myself--
the four of them are faster
sprinters than myself.
So I'm saying like,
what a bloody mess
I've gotten myself
into now because I
can't sprint with these guys.
I've worked all day.
We've built the whole
thing up for Sean.
We've ridden for Sean all day.
And now Sean's back
like, back behind.
I tried getting
away about 5K to go.
But as I was going up
the right-hand side,
the group pulled across and
kind of stopped me a little bit.
But then I came to
the final corner.
I had one guy on my wheel.
It's amazing how the
brain actually works.
Not because of Google, but when
I'm explaining what happens,
I often say, I Googled help.
And it's actually
faster than Google Help.
Because it's amazing how
the brain actually works.
Like, you're going into a
corner, a left-hand corner, 500
meters to go.
The wind's coming
from the right.
So you're analyzing
all this in your brain.
And I reckon I go, I
have one guy on my wheel.
If I go to the right,
because the guy's
going to go to the left,
totally in the wind.
If I go off on the
right, the guy's
going to come on my wheel.
He's going to beat me.
I don't want to be second.
If I wait, I'm
going to be fifth.
What do I do?
So all of a sudden, like,
the brain goes-- chicka,
chicka, chicka,
chika-- keeps going.
And the guys are pulling
into the left-hand side
to close the door.
And I waited till that
door got just enough for me
to get through.
So if the guy behind
me tries to follow me,
he might just
hesitate a little bit.
So I went through
the gap, got through.
That actually happened.
The guys in the group were
Sorensen, van Vliet, and Ralph
[INAUDIBLE], all sprinters.
But all are fighting
with each other.
So once again, I was going--
chicka, chicka, chicka-- going
again.
And these guys are
looking at each other.
Because if leads there,
one's going to be beaten.
So I might gain a
few seconds there.
That's what happened.
I went on the left-hand side.
The guy behind me got blocked.
The other side are
looking at each other.
I got 10 yards, 15
yards, 20 yards.
And that was enough then, to
hold them off to the finish.
And then Sean, of course,
then, was in the group behind.
They caught this small group
about 20, 30 yards to go.
And Sean, of course,
finished sixth.
So it was an amazing final.
But I only won, really, two,
wons the races in my career.
One was the World Championships.
And the other a
Paris-Roubaix Amateur.
So there wasn't that kind of a--
I was more of an endurance
and a tour rider.
But it's amazing how things go--
chicka, chicka, chicka-- click.
And at the last
minute and that's
amazing how fast the
brain has to adapt
to the different circumstances.
GARETH MORGAN: And of course,
it wrapped up a fantastic
banner year, 1987.
I think we're
almost out of time.
I was going to
say, Stephen, it's
wonderful to have
you here at Google.
And it's wonderful to have
you as a Google customer.
You have a thriving
cycling business,
which I believe we're
helping you with.
And it's going well.
STEPHEN ROCHE: Yeah,
the Cycling Holidays now
are going on 21 years now,
stephenrochecyclingholidays.com.
We have almost 70%
repeat loyalty clients,
we've got very loyal clients.
And it's basically a program
we have in Spain in Mallorca,
where we have five groups every
day for five different levels.
So everybody here can
find a level of their own.
And we have two ride
captains in each group
which actually make
sure the speed is
kept to a certain speed.
They don't leave anybody behind.
The following cart, make sure
we have drinks and everything
else, as in water
and electrolytes,
not in alcoholic drink.
And we have three lovely
hotels which we always
keep our people in.
And we have between 60 and
80 people a week for February
through to June, and
then September, October.
And in between we do a
private guiding, bike rentals,
and everything else.
And this year, of course,
for the 30th anniversary,
we're going back to that
famous state in La Flange,
where we're organizing in June.
We're calling it letape87.com
We have our own website.
And we're having
a three-day event
where we arrive at the Grenoble
on the Friday night, June 9th.
Saturday morning we do a
Grenoble Bourg d'Oisans,
up Alpe d'Huez.
70K only, but Alpe d'Huez.
And the Dauphine, which is the
second-biggest tour in France
will arrive one hour behind us.
And the tour contenders
will be there as well
for the second-to-last
stage of the Dauphine.
Next day we start at
Bourg d'Oisans, which
is where the Stage 21 started.
Bourg d'Oisans, over
[INAUDIBLE] telegraph.
Down at the [INAUDIBLE]
where we have lunch.
And then we have to the
limit will be to [INAUDIBLE]..
Then you get a bus to the hotel.
And over limit will
leave [INAUDIBLE]
and go over the Madeleine,
down the far side, which
is the second climb
of the famous stage.
Next morning we do Brides-les
Bains, back on the stage
again, up into La Plagne,
finishing on top of La Plagne,
to have completed
the full stage.
GARETH MORGAN: Great.
STEPHEN ROCHE: So it's a
fairly kind of monumental stay.
But there's no time on it.
We have following
cars, motorbikes.
There are only going
to about 30 people
on it, 30, 35 people on
it, fully-guided motorbikes
and ride captains,
lovely hotels.
So we're looking forward to it.
And hopefully we will
have some names on it
as well, where we haven't
got full agreements yet
from the likes of
Indurain, Delgado.
I'm trying to get
Delgado to come back.
And we lit the stage.
But this time, not collapsing.
And for the fun of it,
so it'll be a few names
that'll be coming along with
us, either for three days
or for one of the days.
Even Eddie Merckx
we're talking to also.
Maybe he might
come along and ride
that, at the last few
kilometers with us.
So we're doing that.
And also, we have
a lighthouse tour
at the end of the year,
which is in Mallorca, which
is four days around the island.
Every day, changing
hotels for four days.
Which is something we've done
for the last two years now.
And that's been a great success.
So the cycling
holidays are booming.
There are many guys
out there doing it.
I was one of the first
guys doing it 21 years ago.
Now there's hundreds
of them doing it now.
But we're still there.
And we like to boast ourselves
as being one of the best.
GARETH MORGAN: Good.
So there's a cycling holiday
for everybody in the audience?
STEPHEN ROCHE: Everybody
in the audience.
stephenroche.com.
GARETH MORGAN: If
the price is right.
Stephen, wonderful
to have you here.
Thank you very much.
And good luck with
your business.
your commentating
over the next three
weeks for the Giro.
STEPHEN ROCHE:
Thank you very much.
Hope you all enjoyed it.
We didn't give you much
time to talk, did we?
Unfortunately, didn't
get any questions in.
It's unfortunate.
GARETH MORGAN: Well,
you're sticking around
for a few minutes.
STEPHEN ROCHE: Yeah,
sure, yeah, yeah.
GARETH MORGAN: And
happy to ask question.
All right.
STEPHEN ROCHE: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]